Gut.
Hallo, guten Tag.
Ich bin Dr. Matt.
Ich bin zuständig aus für Sie.
Ich möchte mit Ihnen über Egerbeschwerden sprechen.
Aber so als bloche ich ein paar Pöse nicht an Daten.
Dann sprechen wir nur über Egerbeschwerden.
Wie lautet Ihr Name?
Mein Name ist Wilhelm Austermann.
Könnten Sie bitte Egerbeschwerden?
Ja.
A S T E R M A N
Und cursed Name, bitte?
Wilhelm, W I L H Wilhelm
Herr Austermann, ja.
Austermann, ja.
Austermann, OK.
Wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 56 Jahre alt.
16,50 Jahre alt. Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Am 1. Februar 1967.
1. Februar 1967, ja.
Ja.
Okay. Wie groß sind Sie und wie viel wiegen Sie?
Ausdauern mal.
Ich wiege 70 Kilo und ich bin 1,80 m hoch.
80?
80, okay.
Was kann ich für Sie tun?
Herr Ausdauern mal.
Ja, ich habe seit 2 Tagen ziemlich starke Bauchschmerzen.
Seit 2 Tagen.
Und das wird aber immer schlimmer.
Die Schmerzen werden stärker.
Wo haben Sie diese Schmerzen genau?
Mehr im oberen Bauch.
Rechter Seite oder die andere Seite?
Dankeweise gehen die Schmerzen mehr in der Mitte und links.
Teilweise gehen die Schmerzen auch in den Rücken.
Und den Geschulter.
Linken Schuter.
Und Rücken, ja.
Okay.
Gibt es bestimmte Auswahl?
Also ich kann nicht gut mich bewegen.
Ich bleibe lieber liegen oder sitzen.
Aber die Beweging geht nicht gut.
Da werden die Schmerzen noch stärker.
Soweit ich verstanden habe,
diese Schmerzen mit der Bewegung abhängig.
Ja, etwas.
Bei Bewegung ist es etwas stärker.
Aber sie sind insgesamt sehr stark.
Wie stark sind die Schmerzen?
Auf einer Schmerz sind sie von 0 bis 10 vorbei.
Aber 0 ist nicht sehr stark.
Im Anfang war es vielleicht 6, aber jetzt ist es 8.
Ich habe bemerkt, dass die sehr starken Schmerzen haben.
Herr Ausdormann, aber leider kann ich Ihnen keine Schmerzmittel geben.
Diese Schmerzmittel können unsere Kölpädikeruntersuchung verfalschen.
Ich bitte Sie, bis unser Gespräch auszukaufen.
Ja, ist okay.
Können Sie bitte diese Schmerzen genau überschreiben?
Sie können die Schmerzen erheben, drücken, brennen.
Sie sind mir so dumpf und drückend.
Ist Ihnen über?
Ja, mir ist in den letzten Stunden ziemlich übel.
Ich habe auch dreimal heftig erbrochen.
Ich habe allerdings auch jetzt gar nichts mehr gegessen.
Aber ich musste mich erbrechen.
Wie ist das Ihre Erbrochenau?
Wie es aussieht?
Ich würde sagen, gelbischleimig.
Gehört das Sie sich besser, nachdem Sie erbrochen haben?
Nein, besser nicht.
Haben Sie Piva?
Nein, ich glaube nicht.
Wie laden Sie unter Schuttefrost, Schwarzausbrücher oder schützten Sie ihn danach?
Schüttelfrost nicht, aber ich muss stark schwitzen.
Ist die Schtulgang oder was das normal ist?
Ich hatte bisher keinen Schmerzen.
Sonst war der Stuhlgang immer normal.
Haben Sie noch andere Beschwärze?
Nein, ich hatte diese Schmerzen vor einem Jahr auch schon.
Aber links nicht so stark.
Wie ist die Schmerzung?
Seitdem ich die Schmerzen habe, habe ich mich nicht mehr groß belastet.
Ich konnte es gar nicht.
Ich habe hauptsächlich auf dem Sofa gelegen oder im Sessel gesessen.
Haben Sie in der Lesterzeit abordnungsbeginn genommen?
Nein, ich habe vielleicht etwas Gewicht abgenommen, in einem Jahr 3 kg.
Wie ist der Appetit?
Normalerweise habe ich immer sehr gut gegessen.
Aber im letzten Jahr habe ich den Eindruck, dass ich sie nicht mehr so gut vertragen habe.
Herr Ausdörmer, haben Sie noch andere Beschwärze?
Nein, ich habe noch andere Beschwärze.
Ich habe noch andere Beschwärze.
Herr Ausdörmer, haben Sie noch andere Beschwärze?
Ich habe keine anderen Beschwärze.
Ich kann verstehen.
Nun möchte ich mit Ihnen über Ihre Vorgeschichte sprechen.
Leiden Sie an irgendwelchen Vorerkrankungen?
Ja, ich habe schon seit einigen Jahren meinen Arzt gesagt, ich rauche zu viel.
Ich habe mehrere Gichtanfälle schon gehabt, in großen Zähnen.
Das war sehr schmerzhaft.
Meine Hansache ist zu hoch.
Im halben Jahr spüre ich häufiger Brennen in den Unterschenkeln und Füßen.
Besonders wichtig ist das Gefühl.
Da möchte ich meinen Hausarzt jetzt zu einem Neurologen schicken, dass das untersucht wird.
Welcher Seite hat denn Sie die Gichtanfälle?
Auf der linken Seite.
Dringmal bisher.
Seit wann leiden Sie unter Erlhoherin Säure?
Hansäure?
Ja, schon zehn Jahre.
Zehn Jahre schätze ich.
Nehmen Sie dagegen irgendwelche Medikamente rein.
Nehmen Sie den Moment, das Mittel heißt Alu-Porinol 300.
Morgens eineter.
Und wegen der Bronchitis nehme ich schon die meiste Zeit im Jahr.
Ganz selten ist die Bronchitis besser.
Im Sommer ist die meiste etwas besser.
Aber im Herbst und den ganzen Winter überbrauche ich Spree.
Dann nehme ich mal Salbuta Molspray und einmal Viani.
Wie Viani heißt das?
Seit wann leiden Sie an Bronchitis?
Bestimmt auch.
Seben Jahre hat sich das verstärkt.
Okay.
Nehmen Sie Salbuta Molspray?
Salbuta Mol und Sal...
Könntest du wieder Hause?
Salbuta Mol?
Salbuta Mol nehme ich Tag in der Regel, dreimal je nachdem, wie schlecht es mir geht.
Und Viani nehme ich zweimal am Tag.
Okay.
Leiden Sie noch andere Folagranken?
Ja, ich habe noch hohe Skolesterieb.
Und die Kokisperinwerte, der hat ihn auch behandelt mit einer Medikamente.
Simvastatin 20 steht dahinter.
Dann nehme ich eine Tablette am Abend.
Seit wann leiden Sie daran?
Ja, auch so...
so sagen wir mal, seit ungefähr ein Jahr.
Ihr habt Akustik nicht verstanden,
könnt ihr Sie wieder ohne Zeit fahren?
Zirka sechs Jahren.
Okay.
Was noch?
Sonst nehme ich keine Medikamente ein.
Keine Medikamente?
Leiden Sie noch andere Folagranken?
Nein.
Okay.
Sind Sie schon mal operiert worden?
Ja, als Kind.
Da war ich neun Jahre alt.
Da bin ich am Glindern operiert worden.
Und mit 20 Jahren, da war ich 20 Jahre alt,
da hatte ich einen Motorradunfall.
Und da hatte ich einen Schenkelbruch auf der rechten Seite.
Und da bin ich operiert worden auch.
Was für ein Bruch haben Sie?
Könnten Sie wieder ohne?
Am Unterschenkel, am rechten Unterschenkel war gebrochen.
Okay.
Was sind die Operationen und Kommunikationen?
Ja, das war normal.
Das war alles gut.
Okay.
Wurden Sie ausnahm Grundstationen aufgenommen?
Sonst war ich noch nie im Krankenhaus,
bis auf diese beiden Operationen.
Okay.
Sind bei Ihnen allergienbekannt, Herr Ausdörmer?
Nein.
Anergien habe ich nicht.
Vertragen Sie mich Produkte, getreite Produkte,
obsologenmüse?
Das vertrage ich alles.
Aber in letzter Zeit habe ich gesagt,
es ist mein Appetit etwas schlechter geworden,
da esse ich nicht mehr so viel Obst.
Aber ich vertrage das.
Rauchen Sie?
Ja, deswegen habe ich wahrscheinlich meine chronische Bronchitis.
30 Jahre und eine Schachtel am Tag.
Okay.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, abends trinke ich so zwei Flaschen Bier.
Und auch so ein bis zwei Schäpse.
Ein bis zwei Schnaps, ja.
Okay.
Routinemäßig muss ich fragen, ob Sie Kontakt mit einem Drogen haben.
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Was ist Ihr Familienstadt?
Ich bin im Land.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, drei Kinder.
Die sind gesund.
Die haben auch etwas heuchtenupfen.
Aber sie müssen keine Medikamente nehmen.
Die sind gesund.
Was sind Sie vom Beruf?
Ich bin Elektriker.
Leiden Sie um Tabu?
Nein.
Nun möchte ich mit Ihnen über Ihre Familiengeschichte sprechen.
Herr Ausdromann, gibt es in der Familie eine Polarkraftung?
Ja.
Mein Vater ist mit 80 Jahren an Lungenkrebs gestorben.
Der hat auch sehr stark geraucht.
Es tut mir leid.
Die Mutter, die lebt, die ist 86 Jahre alt.
Die hat hohen Blutwurk.
Sie hat Arthrose.
Schwere Hüfte.
Aber sie möchte sich nicht mehr operieren lassen.
Dazu sei sie zu alt.
Ich habe noch einen Bruder.
Der ist 88 Jahre alt.
Der hat Galensteine.
Er hat die Galensteine in den nächsten Wochen operiert.
Er hat auch hohe Blutwurke.
Das war meine Frage.
Haben Sie eine Frage?
Was kann das sein?
Ich kann mir das nicht erklären.
Ich kann nicht genau sagen.
Was Sie haben, Herr Ausdromann.
Ich brauche auch ein paar Untersuchungen.
Nachdem die alle Ergebnisse da sind,
werde ich genau sagen, was Sie haben.
Aber ich werde so eine EKG schreiben.
Und so wie ein Ultraschall durchführen.
Ich werde auch eine EKG schreiben.
Dann besprechen.
Ich nehme Blut ab.
Ich bespreche mit meinem Obererstoff noch einmal.
Das können wir so machen.
Haben Kollegen oder Kollegen eine andere Frage?
Ich muss jetzt mein Laptop ein bisschen hoch halten.
sonst kann ich sie schlecht verstehen.
Kollegen, habe ich Fragen?
Können die Schmerzen dauerhaft oder gehen Sie auch wieder weg?
Nein, eigentlich sind die Schmerzen, die Schmerzen sind andauernd dauerhaft.
Vielleicht kommen Sie manchmal dann etwas stärker, aber sonst sind Sie immer da, Sie gehen nicht weg.
Sind Sie deswegen schon bei einem anderen Ernest gewesen?
Nein, bei der Schmerz nicht, nicht bei meinem Hausarzt.
Vor einem Jahr hatte ich ja auch schon mal so starke Schmerzen, das war allerdings im Urlaub.
Das dauerte dann zwei, drei Tage, aber die Schmerzen waren nicht so stark wie jetzt.
Aber sie waren ähnlich.
Dritten, die Beschwerden verbunden mit dem Nahrungsaufnahme auf?
Nein.
Das hat der Kollege, glaube ich, gefragt.
Ich habe seit her kaum etwas gegessen.
Ich habe keine Abitur, seitdem ich diese Schmerzen habe.
Und insofern kann ich das nicht sagen, ob Sie mit der Nahrungsaufnahme verbunden sind.
Ich habe es nicht gesagt, ich habe es nicht gesagt, ich habe es nicht gesagt,
ob Sie mit der Nahrungsaufnahme verbunden sind.
Wie sind die Schmerzen aufgetreten, langsam oder plöselig?
Nicht ganz plötzlich auf, aber es baute sich dann sehr schnell auf der Schmerz, innerhalb von zwei, drei Stunden.
Sie haben gesagt, seit zwei Tagen haben Sie nicht auf der Toilette gegangen.
Gehen, Winde ab, Herr Ostermann.
Ja, ja.
Letzte Stuhlgang, wie aus und üren.
Winde habe ich nicht gelassen. Wasser lassen ist kein Problem.
Danke schön.
Das war meine…
Okay.
Könnte mir erst jetzt gesprungen beginnen?
Gut.
Hallo Herr Oberarzt, wir haben einen neuen Patient, nämlich William Ostermann.
Ich würde über Ihren Berichten. Darf ich?
Ja, bitte.
Ja, Herr Ostermann ist 56 Jahre alt, 1,80 Meter groß, 70 Kilogramm schwer.
Er stattet sich heute bei uns wegen seit zwei Tagen bestätigender, dunkler, drückender und dauerhafter Oberbau-Schmerzen links vor.
Diese Schmerzen schrallen in die linke Schulter und in den Rücken aus.
Okay.
Als Begleiter in der Saptome klagte er über Neusea dreimalige MS, hyperhydrosa, inapetanz,
sowie Gewichtsverlust von 3 Kilogramm in einem Monat, seit der Schmerzen im Jahr.
Ja.
Gewichtsverlust von 3 Kilogramm innerhalb eines Jahres.
Die Schmerzintensität wurde auf einer Schmerztekala von 0 bis 10, am Anfang mit 6, jetzt mit 8 eingeschutucht.
Außer dem sind die Schmerzen mit dem Nahrungsaufgleich nicht verbunden.
Ja, die vegetative Anamnesen ergab zu dem inapetanz.
Anfragranken sind bei ihm die Folgenden bekannt.
Seit 10 Jahren Rikopati und dreimal Poderra im Jahr.
Ja, außer seit 7 Jahren Bronchitis, sowie seit 6 Jahren Hypercholesterinämie.
Er nimmt Allopurinol 300 Meter am Morgen.
Chronische Bronchitis.
Ja, chronische Bronchitis.
Aufgesilte Nachfragen, meine Kollegen nicht.
Chronische Bronchitis.
COPD.
Ich habe Akustis nicht.
Hat der Patient blutig erbrochen?
Nein.
Das Erbrochen sieht geltlich aus.
Okay, okay.
Ist es Risikofaktoren bei den Patienten?
Hat der Patient Risikofaktoren?
Ja.
Der Patient hat Hypercholesterinämie.
Und er raucht 30 Jahre lang anschafter.
Auch der Patient?
Wie bitte?
Ja, 35 Package jetzt.
35 Package jetzt.
Ja, genau.
Gibt es weitere Risikofaktoren?
Für Siropidio, oder?
Insgesamt.
Der Patient raucht seit 35 Jahren.
35 Package jetzt.
Der Alkoholkonsum?
Alkoholkonsum.
Übermäßige Alkoholkonsum.
2 Fleisch Bier.
Und 1 bis 2.
Was trinkt der Patient?
1 bis 2 Schnaps.
2 Schnaps zwischen Bier und noch etwas dazu?
Schnaps.
Okay.
Hat der Patient diese Beschwerden schon mal gehabt?
Ja.
Er hat ähnliche Beschwerden schon seit einem Monat gehabt.
Aber das war nicht so stark.
Ein Monat und ein Jahr.
Der Patient hat vor einem Jahr ähnliche Beschwerden gehabt,
aber die nicht so stark.
Ja.
Vor einem Jahr.
Andere Beschwerden.
Könnte sie wiederholen?
Hat der Patient noch andere Beschwerden?
Ja, nausea, MSI.
Ja, das sind akute Beschwerden.
Der Patient hat auch über Beschwerden in letzter Zeit.
Die Bilitätsstörungen.
Könnte sie wiederholen?
Der Patient hat berichtet, dass er in den letzten Monaten
Sensibilitätsstörungen in den Beinen hat.
Und deswegen bald zum Neurologen geht,
zu einer neurologischen Untersuchung.
Der Patient berichtet über Sensibilitätsstörungen.
Ich habe nur Giftanfälle geholt und vor Darin.
Ja, bald ist das auch schlecht verstanden.
Durch die schlechte Internetverbindung.
Ist der Patient voroperiert?
Ja, als Kind wurde bei ihm Appendoktomie durchgeführt.
Außerdem ist er wegen Unterschenkertfrakturrechts
operiert worden.
Und 20 Jahre.
Ja, er wurde mit Appendoktomiert und mit 20 Jahren
am rechten Unterschenkel aufgrund einer Unterschenkelfraktur
mit einer Ostiosynthese.
Gut.
Gibt es Auffälligkeiten in der Familienvorgeschichte?
Ja, der Vater des Patienten ist an einem Lungenkarzium
verstorben.
Lungenkarzium? Ja.
Und die Mutter?
Ja.
Und die Mutter des Patienten leidet an Arteriellhypertony
und Kokosatrosa.
Der Bruder des Patienten ist wegen Cholilitiasis operiert worden.
Soll wegen Cholilitiasis operiert werden?
Er ist noch nicht operiert worden, aber er soll operiert werden.
Was ist Ihre Verdachtstiagnose?
Die an einem Nestischeangaben-
Eine Diagnose bei den Patienten.
Deuter Name ist dann auf eine Pantreatitis hin.
Differenziatriagnostisch kommen auch akut-
akut Coronasandrom, Sundrom in Betrag.
Ja.
Okay, muss einmal aufdehnen.
Akute Pankreatitis, da kann ich.
Akute Pankreatitis, das kann gut sein.
Es ist, glaube ich, von der Anamnese her, ein,
vor ein Jahr hatte der Patient wahrscheinlich im vorigen Jahr,
vor einem Jahr hatte der Patient wahrscheinlich schon mal
eine Pankreatitis.
Akut, chronische Pankreatitis.
Vor einem Jahr.
Man kann jetzt sagen, es ist jetzt inzwischen eine chronische Pankreatitis
und da hat er einen akuten Schub.
Dafür spricht die leichte Gewichtsabnahme des Patienten.
Dafür spricht die Aufregung wahrscheinlich auf dem,
vor dem Hintergrund, Alkoholkonsums.
Der Patient hat einen übermäßigen Alkoholkonsum.
Wenn er berichtet zwei Flaschen Bier am Abend und mehrere Schnäpsel,
kann es sein, dass es auch noch mehr ist.
Jedenfalls glaube, ist anzunehmen, dass er eine Begleit
alkoholische Neuropathie hat.
Die Kribbelparin besonders macht die Sensibilitätsstörungen
und so weiter und das soll jetzt ja untersucht werden,
demnächst beim Neurologen.
Okay, es war jetzt für Sie besonders schwierig,
für mich auch, das alles immer zu verstehen, vom Ton her.
Das bitte ich zu entschuldigen, aber es geht hier nicht besser.
Ich denke, Sie haben das doch systematisch gemacht.
Denken Sie bitte daran, dass Sie, wenn Sie jetzt sagen,
der Patient hat akute Beschwerden, dass Sie dann aber auch noch sagen,
vor einem Patient ähnliche Beschwerden, aber nicht so stark.
Das ist schon ein wichtiger an amnestischer Hinweis,
vielleicht auf eine doch jetzt inzwischen chronisch
präzidivierende Frankreatitis.
Sie haben die Fachbegriffe nausea, wo, denke ich,
gut übersetzt in die Medizinsprache.
Und das ist Ihnen gut gelungen.
Alles andere war für Sie besonders schwierig aufgrund der technischen
Probleme, die wir heute Abend hier haben.
Aber das ist für mich ein Vielen Dank.